the latest cbs news battleground tracker
asks registered voters which
presidential candidate would do a better
job handling the covitt outbreak
voters chose democratic nominee joe
biden over president trump
50 to 38 percent the poll also shows
biden with a 10 point lead in the race
among likely voters
he travels to harrisburg pennsylvania
today for a labor day event focused on
unions
and working families as ed o'keefe
reports his running mate is questioning
the president's push
for a coronavirus vaccine
i will say that i would not
trust donald trump and it would have to
be
a credible source of information that
talks about the
the efficacy and the and the reliability
of whatever he's talking about
democratic vice presidential candidate
kamala harris says she wouldn't trust
just president trump's word on a
coronavirus vaccine
if one's available before the election i
will not take his word for it he wants
us to
inject bleach no i will not take his
word and harris isn't alone
a new cbs news battleground tracker poll
finds skepticism about a vaccine is on
the rise
nearly two-thirds of voters say that if
a vaccine is released later this year
they'd think it was probably rushed
without enough testing
rather than a scientific achievement
that happened quickly
and as protests continue across the
country the poll finds more voters see
democratic presidential candidate joe
biden
is trying to calm the situation while
president trump is perceived to be
encouraging
fighting mr trump has spent the last
several weeks raising concerns about a
potential spike in violence in the
nation's suburbs
biden and the radical left's weak
response has led to chaos and violence
but the poll finds most people think
it's not likely violent protests will
happen
in their neighborhood we do have two
systems of justice in america harris who
set the campaign in wisconsin today on
sunday also criticized attorney general
bill barr for denying that systemic
racism exists
in the criminal justice system there's
no question that we have seen an
unacceptable incident for generations of
unarmed black men being killed
nobody can deny that
still 57 days to go until the election
but joe biden is now legally required to
start thinking about a potential
transfer of power
by law he's opening a transition office
here in washington
and that staff is going to be advised by
a handful of interesting people
including one of his former primary
rivals pete buttige and a few of the
women that he considered
to be his running mate including the
former white house national security
adviser susan rice
and new mexico governor michelle lujan
grisham
dana a lot of unity there ed and i want
to point out tony and i
we need the white board i'm glad the
white board has the days to the election
we can count on it back there
what about me michelle does as well i'm
just learning yes
57